[Music]
how does it feel being back good I had
such good memories here maybe my happy
place can be our happy place we left you
all alone down here it was just my
imagin I'm playing a new game with chy
the scavenger hunt list that's fun chy
says you're not allowed to play with us
oh because you left him I need something
happy something happy oh I thought bugs
freaked you out if I can finish my list
try will take me on a trip to the place
he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice you've been spending time with a
new
[Music]
friend he ask you to do something that
hurt you that was part of the game does
that seem like a game a good friend
would want to play maybe we shouldn't
play together anymore chy maybe we
shouldn't be friends no no no
no Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice she's lost but we're going to find
her
every culture has entities that tether
to the young we call them imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
enraged he says he's right behind
you but it was just
imagin can I hang out with your
imaginary friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
[Music]
friend